the coach of the Saints
Thanks that's special right there and
pretty useful for making it look easier
than it already was yeah that was
tremendous trying to keep his balance
Clippard perfectly if there's anybody
that could do it it's pretty good there
on down grabbed a little more than he
thought Oh a shot it's really well done
though to his right
big one right there birdies filter great
putt
way to go baby Thank You partner yeah
mark that one down
come on catch that he'll catch it
come on kid listen so I want a shot oh
good try babe I was 25 mil a little hard
kick needs to take it right over the
corner of those pine trees
oh yes sir this is looking pretty good
right here touch long but I tried to
check it out in my shot it might be a
touch long all right drivable par-4 has
been driven milk until he's gonna love
that mmm that credit to Brady for
freedom up as well hit a good one yes
you need a little luck I think it's good
but I don't you know I'm played here
enough to know come on baby give us a
look at it Phil I don't want to give
away how good this is but I want to just
see what your reaction here when you
pull up to the green oh yeah that's what
I'm talking about
hitting bombs high nasty straight bombs
oh it landed three feet from the content
it was bit was pure it was right on it
you did hit it a little too long that is
salty mm-hmm are using a bowl it
wouldn't be surprised if one of these
guys knocked it close here baby give me
you're gonna tell me please come on back
come on back
was this a 25 mil the old I'm gonna
wasn't okay all right I thought it was I
like how he asked that like you were
gonna try harder were a big part of the
day
[Music]
what a lot just dialed it in center cut
if I dude here we're going down three to
go
let's go throw it in there tight yeah
walking up to the corner baby beautiful
Hills made a couple of big ones last two
haunts to earn a couple nice
take left come on come on just checked
up